[موسيقى]
يظهر على قرص شمس بين ان واخر بقع سوداء
لها اشكال متنوعه ومتحركه في وسطها تسمى
عند الفلكيين بالبقع او الكلفى الشمسيه
والبقعه او الحبه السوداء اذا ظهرت على
البدن يسميها العرب الاقحاح بشامه والعامه
يسمونها بحبه الخال وهي من مقومات الجمال
عندهم خاصه اذا ظهرت على الخد شاميه في
خدها شامه يرق لي في حبها الشامته اخشاه
اذا قبلتها حليتها مخافه ان ينطقوا
الصامت
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والبقع او الكلف الشمسيه لها دوره على قرص
الشمس وبعض العلماء يعتقد ان لهذه الدوره
علاقه وطيده بالتغيرات المناخيه نزول
المطر والاعاخير والجفاف وغيرها فالدورها
الواحده اللي هي 11 سنه يحصل فيها ثلاث
سنوات مطيره ان يحصل فيها ربيع والربيع
هذا يكون في بقعه دون ثانيه والدورتين له
22 سنه في نهايتها يكون الربيع فيها عاما
والثمان دورات 80 سنه يحصل فيها تغيرات
مناخيه عالميه كالاعاصير المدمره ودرجه
الحراره الملهقه والرطوبه الخانقه وفي
الدنيا اذا كانت كذا انا منها في بلائم
واذى انصفى عيش امرئ في صبحها جرعته ممسيا
كاس الردى
[موسيقى]